let's just call the outcome that we want
however we get their carbon justice
let's just call it carbon justice well
think of that as staying below the
guardrail and also giving the people who
haven't had much carbon burn a chance to
burn as much as we have okay so that's
our goal carbon justice let's say you
know one thing you might ask is what
would motivate us to take that on as a
goal after all we're talking about not
just people who are spatially extended
far away from us the global poor the
southern hemisphere for the most part
but also temporarily far away from us so
I talked about expanding the moral we
why do we expand the moral we the us
that we care about the people who have
standing in to non-existent people
future generations philosophers like
these kind of puzzles they don't exist
they don't have rights we don't owe them
anything so why are we so worried about
it maybe we should just go with business
as usual but that feels wrong somehow we
don't tend to think that we have to make
decisions in an effort to produce as
many well-functioning future people as
possible we don't think of condoms as
weapons of mass destruction we don't
think that preventing people from
existing is a bad thing so why do we
worry or feel we have obligations in
some way to future people so there are
some puzzles there that philosophers get
into suppose we do though think that we
have some sort of obligation to keep
things going maybe we just think it's
like an intrinsic good that there be
human beings on the earth then we'll
have to try to see how we can get to
carbon justice the other problem here is
it's a massive collection collective
action issue so not only do we have to
worry about what other nations are going
to decide and the Paris treaty did get
some distance in that regard but we have
to also worry about kind of defectors in
our own communities you know what if I
try really hard and cut way back and
then my neighbor does it looks like he's
not going to in a lot of these games
theoretic contexts when we're talking
about
dilemmas and so forth there you're in a
state of ignorance in this case we're
not even in a state of ignorance it
looks clear that a lot of people are
gonna defect it looks like some nations
that feel they are owed certain carbon
credits may not toe the line so I think
that there's a you know there here's
carbon justice we feel like we want it
for some reason we're obliged morally to
go for it but there's a threat of
demoralization I think we all feel this
my students certainly feel this and I
mean that in two ways sort of double
entendre demoralize psychologically
going after this just starts to seem
like something that's too hard it's
enervating especially when I don't know
if anybody else is gonna really do what
I'm trying to do and then so you lose
your moral the sort of moral driving
force behind your activity you start to
become apathetic or maybe opportunistic
in certain ways you eat drink and be
merry because we're not gonna be able to
fix this so that's a sort of bad thing
from a moral point of view and yet it
seems to be something that we all face
and in spades when you think about
something like the Anthropocene so it
would be great if we could just convince
ourselves sort of leap of faith style
that you know when we act everyone else
will act and somehow we'll get there and
carbon justice will be achieved but that
just looks irrational it looks like bad
faith maybe there's a pragmatic reason
for going in that direction in some
cases but this looks like it'd be hard
to do and also a little bit irrational
and so what I want to do is develop a
conception of hope that might play a
certain sort of motivational role that
allows us to keep going even in the face
of these issues regarding the
Anthropocene and the collective-action
problem but doesn't require a kind of
irrationality
[Music]
you